Point is, Colin, we don't not care.
We care very much.
We care about who you are and what you
must have been going through.
Yeah?
Hey, from now on, you don't have to go through it
all by yourself.
Yeah.
All right?
[OVERLAPPING VOICES]
100% got you.
Hear that.
You've got us, mate.
We've got you.
OK.
Well, look, hey, I hate to bring up work in a moment like this,
but we do have a second half of a match to play.
Coach, what have we got?
Playing a man down.
What do we do differently?
Absolutely nothing.
[CHEERS, APPLAUSE]
Let's go.
Come on.
Nice one.
Let's go.
OK, OK.
All right.
Captain, count us off.
Oh, wow.
That's me.
Yes.
OK.
I don't know what to say.
I'm honored to be your captain.
And I love you guys so very much.
On 3.
1, 2, 3.
I love you guys so very much!
[CHEERING]